hallo darla punk'd thea gervin und nash
rechnen lexi waisen verfolgen und krishna
vas ostern vas ist das härteste zeit
boo Duff ist uncool ist zäh ein holz
ist also ein alaun pro neun also ist irgendwie
klumpig nein das ist irgendwie klumpig also ist
zeit glas so  East Ich bin Glas, wenn hart
im Bett estas Ich wette, neun hart ist nett
acht neun härteste Art bisschen Stein
Sofawurf ist ich bin Ruffa, es gibt Sachen,
es gibt
Personalwurf ist Nicole, also East Nicole
c-ruhige Werkzeuge Lawson siehe Comp  von Lawson-
Mitarbeitern speisen finden ist Dustin finden neun
härteste
NICHD-Mann Front neun härteste NICHD mein
Freund müssen aufdecken finden müssen -
geprägt in neun einander
keine Finanzierung neun einander Art der
Rundung passiert e freundlicher verhärtet das
Königreich neun er hat einen freundlicheren kinder
neun
Sabich kinder kinder jung-hee havana
doktor yeah einander
reporter splash und wiederholt langsamer
sprechen sie bitte langsam bus editiert
post leitzel bus von Reuters post
lichtzelle v-förmig Manda's umgestaltet Manda's
geht nicht d  wie bitter
geschoben erscheint kann nicht das bitte
geschoben Opiumwährung wird besser
abgespült Ian Währung wird besser
abgespült in jedem Vers liebe Art schreibt
eine Fackel,
wenn
liebe Art Schriftsteller ausweichen geduldig bittere
[ __ ] berühren derzeit bessere [ __ ] ausweichen
kann das nicht Peter  Vida Hulan kann nicht -
Daffy besser Vida Hulan Währung tut
Peter Vida Haulin Währung der Spucker
Vida Hulan hier ist ein bisschen hier ist ein
bisschen wenn Dustin schlissel wenn der
kleine Reim des Steins wirft ein verpfiffener
gedankenloser Neunwurf wird mein kleines
Asien weit vermisst -  pfeife sehr weit
vielleicht - pfeife hier ist blasen
hier ist blasen hier ist aina yucca hier ist
aina yucca
es ist eine harte zeit eine yucca eine harte zeit eine
yucca nein das ist nicht meine eine
yucca nein das ist geschnüffelt
- aku Venture Vater hatte den Yucca
Venture Vater  hatte die yucca der osten
würde der osten kalt hier ist zeit handlich
hier bin ich handlich wenn hart zeit handlich ist
der stein handlich neun
somit ist meine handlich nein das ist
nicht meine handlich Bella schlüsselanhänger ah  ot
dog handy velji farber at Efendi
das ist Vance assist Schwarz ee grill
[Music]
green this this TAS pas de prisa TAS
boo-tee Pasha - Sheila - Sheila - Sheila
- Sheila sie sind Schulbrenner sie
sind Schullehrer Tula aa
meth meth Sparta  Spader die Lund delenda
die Slums delenda ihr Vater tat Feta
ihr Vater d Feta zähes Blut Deeb
Brief
also plus Deeb Brief Erde ist 1212
wer und wen und Diaz besitzen Ethernet Diaz
besessen DeLuna der Topper die Küste die
Tapa de Kirchner der Ort d Wodka der
SWAT  d willkommen